[Music]
thanks everyone my name is Amy Krishnan
I do product marketing at Google Cloud
I'm here with really exciting guest
speakers today Joe and Sam from collide
and the six river system so you're going
to talk a little bit more about this how
you are you can build a SAS application
the cloud-based infrastructure so
science has changed a lot right when you
had more on Prem hardware based
environment having a single Tennessee
was actually really expensive what is
very secure but cloud infrastructure
actually made a really tragic changes in
terms of making these instances
available very easily at your hand the
SAS is obviously making a leading
changes in that area so here are really
introduced our guest from Joe would you
like to take it from here hey I'm Joe
Hughes director of DevOps at six river
systems six River systems is a robotic
company when you get things shipped to
you from you know the internet we have a
big hand in making sure that those
things can get to you in two days or
faster and I was previously at a company
called Amazon robotics in that space and
that you probably would know them as
Kiva they solved the same problem so
that's our robot his name is Chuck and
essentially Chuck leads a worker around
a warehouse using kind of self-driving
technology identifying you know objects
in the way and taking that person to
fulfill your order of toothbrushes or
whatever you happen to order off the
internet this is what those warehouses
look like so you know this isn't your
Home Depot or your Target store this is
thousands and thousands of products
million square-foot warehouses and so we
have you know algorithms in the cloud
that helps helps us batch these orders
and get efficiencies for our customers
and make sure that Chuck or you know the
mini Chuck's that are in these
warehouses coordinate together and make
life better for our
so if you're not familiar with warehouse
robotics to traditional row a
traditionally what you would be doing is
carrying around a big cart raining
upwards of 50 to 100 pounds now you can
follow Chuck around and have a you know
a more enjoyable work day basically this
is just a quick look look at our
high-level architecture and this is kind
of what amy was alluding to is we have a
google kubernetes engine cluster which
is kubernetes is a container scheduler
where we create what are called
namespaces which basically isolate
customers from one another
we actually run these namespaces on
dedicated nodes which is like dedicated
compute and we actually have a dedicated
sequel primary and a read replicas for
every single customer so that means that
data from one in warehouse never gets
mixed with another so that's a little
bit about what I do and what my company
does I'm gonna hand it over to the Ceph
to kind of fill you in on what collide
does hi everyone I'm Steph I'm an SRE
that collide which does sort of
infrastructure analytics and security
analytics previously I've been at fastly
Twitter act blue I like infrastructure
is code data simplification stuff like
that collide builds an endpoint that
hangs out on devices primarily laptops
and collects analytics about that and
sends it into our cloud where we do some
analysis on it we launched cloud which
is our SAS offering about a year ago now
and in that each customer has an
isolated namespace very similar to what
what Joe is doing and each namespace has
its own little stack of application
server and data processing elements and
those backhaul to dedicated cloud sequel
instances so we kind of did that because
it reduces the noisy neighbor problems
it also
shifts the burden of data isolation from
application developers to infrastructure
right we dedicate infrastructure
resources to ensure data segregation and
then we can take it out of the
application we do share our edge ingress
so edge is shared and it then comes in
and gets sort of pushed into the back we
use kubernetes quite extensively
we follow the operator pattern so each
customer has a custom resource
definition and then an operator goes and
reads the CRD spawns the namespace
creates many deployments each one
springs of things brings up cloud sequel
we started running into issues around
the number of namespaces and things that
can be in a single kubernetes cluster so
we have multiple kubernetes clusters now
we found that some of the spin-up times
were a little slow so we started pre
creating unallocated customers and then
on signup would allocate them we are
very soon launching a new product next
week which moves away from the single
tenant architecture and starts or
revisiting multi tenant designs so that
uses foreign keys for a customer data
isolation and you know we can sort of
this is enforced like a data layer by
making sure they're effectively sequel
where clauses all over so it's basically
in our data library and we could chart
that by customer two separate backends I
think that's all I've got
prepared Thanks so before we get started
if there's a Dory open in your mobile
app so if you have any questions feel
free to submit a question we'll take the
questions at the end and so there are
many ways that we can define the
multi-tenant environment right everybody
define in a very different way so how
would you define multi-tenant in the
cloud environment I guess I have the mic
so I'll start I think there is a whole
lot of ways to think about that you know
we run in Google's cloud so inherently
Google's cloud is multi-tenant like
probably what almost everyone in this
room is in Google's cloud
but you know we run on our own
kubernetes cluster but our kubernetes
cluster is also multi-tenant because we
only have you know many of our customers
are in the same kubernetes cluster so
kubernetes cluster singleton but each
daemon or pod inside and kubernetes
workloads are sort of grouped by pod so
a pod is like a set of linked containers
and each pod is single tenants only one
customers in the pod and our underlying
databases we use cloud sequel we have
one cloud sequel instance per customer
so that's also a very clear single
tenant so it kind of depends on where
you look at it I would generally
describe our cloud product as being
single tenant since Google can Google
cloud being multi tenant isn't really
very interesting but like our
applications servers and or database
servers are yeah I don't really have
much to add to that I would say that a
lot of it also comes down to your
business problem and for us you know
when we considered what whether what we
should build and we're like well we have
long lead times with our customers and
they may or may not want us to upgrade
them and so you know what is this
architecture called and it's called
single tenant because we have really
tight control over how our customer
environment is managed that works well
for us but if you're building a social
media platform or something like that
and probably not the right architecture
for you so you're defining it's like
single tenant is having a customer per
pod and and also each single customer
would have a dedicated database
instances yeah and we have we go a step
further and stuff where we actually have
dedicated GCP like Google cloud platform
nodes that kubernetes will only schedule
customer pods and customer workloads
onto those dedicated nodes where I know
Ceph as he spoke about his is more multi
tenant where a customer's pod can end up
on any node and they may move around or
whereas ours we try to protect our
customers by having dedicated compute
kubernetes is so flexible that it
it easy for stuff to do his thing and
for me to do a little bit different so
when you design your architecture what
was your biggest consideration for me
for us it's really about customer
stability you know I think everyone here
would be really angry if the socks that
were guaranteed to come to you in two
days were there two weeks later and if
we caused that because our system was
down for some reason for some time then
our customers aren't going to trust us
so you know we have to really guarantee
that customer egg
you know the noisy neighbor problem it's
it's just not even we can't even let it
enter the equation for our for our
system we had two major drivers for
going single tenant for our last product
one of them was to reduce noisy neighbor
a lot so again you know one customer
does a lot of stuff basically starves
the resources of other people so we
started splitting up resources the other
reason is just around data isolation
again it makes it very easy for an
application developer just not even
think about it right you can be like oh
there's no way I can select data for the
wrong customer it's just that app server
doesn't have access to that so that was
that was a big driver for us going back
there's been more in the database side
have you guys ever tried putting a
multi-tenant in a single database like
maybe separating them by the key so we
we do actually so I mentioned we're
launching a new product or new product
has a shared database so each customer
has a their foreign key constraints
every piece of data is linked to a
customer ID and there are where clauses
all over but again it's just this
trade-off of are you doing the data
isolation work in your application at
the sequel level or at an infrastructure
level so go both ways yeah so our
company you know we another factor of
why we haven't looked into that
situation was just time right like we
knew that there would be trade-offs and
that
more more developer time to do those
sort of things and so where we can shift
complexity away from our developers and
shift it onto Google which is what we
were really doing that's what that made
it an easy call for us to just continue
with that model exercise I think about
this like one of the ongoing trade-offs
for us around number of instances is
there's like straight-up number of
instances you know when we had ten
instances it was easy but like as as the
number of tenants we have increases and
increases we're suddenly now managing
where Google is managing many many many
cloud sequel instances and it mostly
works great but you know as a single
person managing them it gets much harder
for me to track down problems so the
number the number of things to pay
attention to so that we talk about
instances so I'm sure like when your
customers create some their account in
the application I'm sure they want kind
of instant creation right but creating
the database instances or node all the
pod it takes time so how do you manage
that latency issue
I'll start so we have signup is
available online so people can just kind
of go hey I want to sign up and we used
to have a slightly asynchronous signup
flow people would click signup we'd send
them email and then they'd click their
email and behind the scenes while that
email was being delivered we would spin
up a database we'd spin up a tenant and
we had a couple of issues with that one
of them is that we wanted and we wanted
to close that loop even tighter we
didn't want people to have to wait for
their email and the other one is
occasionally instance creation would
fail and we never really built like
failure handily so we solved that by pre
allocating things so you know we are we
have a little daemon it runs in the
background it says make sure there are
you know roughly 30 free tenants at any
given time so we just sort of have a
have Headroom and then when someone
signs up it says hey give me the next
free one gets a free one then it
basically says this is this now belongs
to this company and then it's it's used
and then you know a little while later
the daemon goes oh hey look I need to
create a new free one so we've sort of
tackled that loop
pre-created model how do you come up
with that 30 unallocated yes it just
kind of made it up random number you
know I looked at like what do we get
from the day of sign ups like what's our
peak you know what
how much head room do we want to have
lying around and you know I picked a
number we used to adjust and more often
but now it's for us it's a little bit
easier because you can't just go online
and sign up for Chuck you have to engage
with our team and there's a you know a
long integration period where we have to
integrate with customers system so 10
minute creation time is like lightning
fast for our industry and we're really
happy with that
so I'm saying you both nice are using
the kubernetes right now so how do you
use your kubernetes in your SAS
application yeah you saw a little bit of
that on that my slide where as you know
I think kubernetes is really great
because of its flexibility where you can
isolate things by namespace you know its
yoke and you know we have a lot of
customers are very concerned about
security there's potentially personal
information and some of the things that
we handle and so you know those that
isolation with namespaces and encryption
encryption by default which the itseo
service mesh kind of gives you are all
really powerful tools for us that we we
just get by using the platform so we we
really reach for all of those things to
make it easier to manage a stuff kind of
alluded to you know we've grown our
customer base quite a bit and so there's
you know a non-trivial amount of sequel
instances to manage and there's a
non-trivial amount of namespaces and
pods but you know that's where
stackdriver and a lot of the other
products that Google Offers really come
in to help you but yeah I would say that
the the continuous release of new
features of kubernetes has made it a
really really great thing for us yeah we
love kubernetes it's great
you know I sort of think of it as a it's
a nice abstraction for defining
workloads so we define workloads and
then kubernetes just kind of makes them
happen and we heavily use namespaces as
our isolation model we also have really
done a lot in the kubernetes operator
model which is a thing core OS I don't
know declared a while ago and means
we've we create custom resources
resources are like an internal
kubernetes thing pile of llamó and the
resource basically says this is a
customer they should get this many
resources they're you know big a medium
small and make them go and then we have
an operator that comes along reads all
the resources and creates the namespace
creates all the pods creates the cloud
sequel instance and so yeah I mean
kubernetes is great and I really like
the operator pattern it liked it lets me
take my knowledge of how to create and
manage these things and translate it
into code that just runs and
synchronizes itself and kind of just
goes in the background and fixes fixes
fixes fixes yeah so as you may have
guessed from ami we use terraform we
we're actually on the journey to where
cephalo already is where the operator
pattern we've watched it closely and
kind of seeing people apply it
successfully again we you know we're in
an industry where we have to be a little
bit more cautious so we have to kind of
watch things and make sure that they
mature in the way that we really think
that we can make a long-term bet on them
you know kubernetes is a no-brainer the
operating pattern it is a pattern and so
for us we had to see people successfully
apply it and there's a lot of great
examples out there now and a lot of
great stories from people like seth who
have applied it so that's where we're
gonna be going next
so do you touched about the security so
what kind of things that in the
multi-tenant environment how do you like
isolate its tenant to avoid any security
concern a specific thing that you can
share yeah I think just by the nature of
having that single tenancy you alleviate
almost all of that concern you know
there are certain customers where they
want that data to be on prem and that's
a whole another thing that you have to
address but you know in a multi-tenant
application again i think it's you
really have to go look at your business
case i've worked for companies that were
under HIPAA compliance and so in a
multi-tenant HIPAA a multi-tenant
application that has to have HIPAA
compliance you have to have like row
level encryption and then you have to
reach for some tools like vault which is
a hashey core product that allows you to
have like encryption as a service or you
know other things like that because it's
not just enough that you can add if
somewhere was that access it they can't
even be able to decrypt it and so
business cases like really what you
really need to think about a lot of
these situations yeah I'm not sure I
have much to add on the single tenant
side it is a great answer for a very
strong data isolation as said if you go
multi tenant you're basically pushing
that burden to the application layer
we've often done it you know in our
multi tenant world we do it by the
database adapter just enforces that you
know oh this is a call for data it had
better have a appropriate where tenet
equals x clause on it and frequently to
handle the needs of really sensitive
customers you end up charting by
customer so you end up kind of in a bit
of a hybrid where like most things are
multi tenant but this one is special how
about the noisy neighbor problem how do
you do the performance isolation well
single tenant makes that pretty easy in
kubernetes you still have to think about
it a little bit so we our pods are
scheduled onto the same nodes so we have
to make sure that our pod resource
allocations are correct so each of our
pods is allocated you know so much CPU
and so much RAM and then kubernetes will
just enforce that and that's how we
approach the noisy neighbor problem yeah
I kind of gave it away earlier but yeah
that's you know we actually had a such
we we were doing what Seth did and a bug
in our code essentially was causing
cascading failures where we were
bringing down and anti
node and there was multiple customers on
that node and so our tech support team
had you know a lot of angry phone calls
all at the same time so I ended up
pulling over the side of the road and
doing a lot of work on my laptop on the
side of the highway so after that we
were like okay you know in the future
when we have more resources and and our
company's more mature and we can really
get a lot of great people like Saif and
and other people like that we can attack
this but for now it's easier again to
push that complexity to Google say you
know we're gonna have node pools for
every single customer and we're gonna
set up the kubernetes rules to make sure
that no cut to customers can end up on
the same node so that something does
happen and we roll out a bug like that
again it's gonna be completely isolated
you know that is not a long-term you
know solution probably but for now it's
something that we can live with and it's
helped us continue to build our business
I've actually sort of got a we run into
a certain problem around this which
maybe it's funny if people want to hear
about kubernetes problems you know not
you know what we've what we've seen is
kubernetes itself can be a little weird
it's not quite a noisy neighbor but it's
almost similar like the underlying
kubernetes resource requirements per
node are not small
so they're actually substantial like if
you have a you know each node has a
given load so you have to be cognizant
of that and the other thing we've run
into which is I don't know I giggle
about it but it's been a bit of a pain
point is some operations we do if we go
to like upgrade everyone right we're
basically running a redeploy on every
one of our tenants and what we found is
that the kubernetes master can get
overwhelmed with that very easily and
then everything breaks so it's very bad
when your kubernetes master breaks so to
sort of approach that scaling and kind
of noisy neighbor we basically just rate
limit what we do so we we found that we
have to be very deliberate in how we
roll out upgrades because otherwise the
kubernetes master just tries to do
everything at once and then it melts
it's a home any policy put per node
hahaha this is another problem we've run
into i'm kubernetes running in google
kubernetes has a limit of a hundred and
ten pods per node which most people are
okay with because you normally run about
thirty and this is kind of a pod
resource two node capacity question a
lot of our services are very small and
we have a large number of tenants so we
repack them a bit but what I've found is
when we exceed about 50 things start
going wonky and it's just there's a lot
of auto scaling in the kubernetes system
and a lot of the scaling around
kubernetes metrics collection and logs
collection is based on the idea that you
will only have about 30 pots per node so
as you start pushing that higher and
higher you just you've run into these
points where things you didn't expect
could break would break yes I would
recommend not exceeding 30 to 50 pots
per node experience like maybe in the
breath Black Friday
I'm sure yeah so as all of you would
probably recognize our customers can
have something like a 20x peak where
everyone wants to order something on a
Black Friday and they want it the next
day and so for us that's where
kubernetes really shines for us also is
okay we all of a sudden got 20 times the
orders that our system normally needs to
ingest and so being able to both scale
vertically and horizontally inside
kubernetes gives us the flexibility to
kind of not have to worry about that as
much we obviously take a lot of
precautions and/or try to be ready for
that but as a technology it's really
enabled us to again do more with less
and that's really what I think a
start-up is all about is you know you
need to keep your most talented people
focused on the product and not focused
on oh no we need more notes quick click
the button more and that's you know
that's where kubernetes comes in maybe
maybe sort of thinking a bit about that
though this might be a future question I
don't know sorry Amy
like one of the things that helps us a
lot in handling sort of momentary bursts
and traffic is we have a predominantly
asynchronous pipeline you know we're
trying to reason about things on them
like minute to couple of minute time
line so if a big burst comes in it's
kind of just gonna hang out in a cube
until we can process it so as long as
our queues have capacity it's okay if
our processing is a little bit lagging
and I can't speak for Joe but I bet
there's something similar we're getting
there you know I think yeah you think
about logistics and these companies they
they're often very very old and so we're
integrating with systems that expect
transactions for example so we don't
care that we gave you like two million
things to do we're just gonna sit here
and wait for you to tell us if you did
two million things so a lot of our
infrastructure needs to just really be
able to absorb that we do some batching
and everything else but it's it's a
problem that is difficult to solve and
the infrastructure can't always solve
that problem but good design where you
build queues and everything else can can
help now let's move on to more
customizability so you guys have a
single tenant environment so if how
similar to each tenant the
characteristic and if the one tenant is
a very different characteristic how do
you customize those things yeah that's a
that's a really good question for us you
know it's a kind of around the size of
our system so customer a has eight eight
Chuck's and customer B has 50 we we have
kind of like we put those numbers in and
out the other side pops well they should
get this size of database or the they
should get this size of you know note
pool or read this amount of resources
because we know kind of exactly how it
Chuck's gonna behave it's a little bit
more difficult if you have users or
other things that you don't really you
can't really predict but luckily we kind
of control both sides of the equation
there so it can be really really
prescriptive for us we probably have
about maybe five variables per customer
don't remember offhand but it's about
five and we implement that by
environmental variable so the our
application says hey what you know the
value of this environmental variable and
it behaves a little differently and then
we just control those in our Cooper
Nettie's operator pattern our custom
resource definition has some settings
the operator pushes those in as
deployment variables and then it all
just kind of follows from there so now
let's move on to cross tenant
environment so when you need to do like
analytics the cross tenant environment
how do you do that are using any data
warehousing environment we don't have
that need so we haven't done it we do as
you would imagine really want to know
about all of our customers and so it is
an interesting problem for us and we use
big we rely on bigquery a lot and so all
of our robots are sending information
through cloud IOT that gets pumped into
bigquery and then we also have some data
pipelines that go and go to all of our
sequel instances and scrape data shove
it into bigquery so we have one place
where we can look at all of that and
we're lucky enough to be involved with
kind of an alpha where cloud sequel is
able to be queried by bigquery directly
and so we'll be happy to kind of get rid
of that scraping situation but yeah it's
it's really important that is something
that it takes a little is a good thing
to reason about is if you're gonna have
that neat
you know stuff doesn't but we definitely
do because we need to find efficiencies
across all of our tenants and so that's
really important for us and how do you
four kiss your demand the capacity
planning now you talked about the 30
I mean our our capacity planning is
relatively simple we sort of look at
what our marketing is like and you know
are we going to a conference do we
expect signups
thing and then we just kind of say about
this and we do it and you know
overestimate it a little bit don't think
too hard you know we're still a very
small company we don't we don't have
this I guess the other sort of implicit
piece of that is you know we don't have
to buy hardware you know we're just
saying hey Google you know instead of 30
give me 32 right like it it's no
different to me minute either way yeah I
think yeah we also have a pretty nice
luxury where we kind of know our
customers even tell us how many orders
they expect on their like Black Friday
and so we you know we prepare for that
by doing a lot of load testing and that
really helps us understand oh we need to
scale it like this needs to auto scale
this way or we need to prepare our
environment this way so a little easier
for us because we're dealing with large
enterprise businesses yeah actually one
of the cool things that we do in
kubernetes as you probably can imagine
if we need to test a hundred robots we
can't really just go with a hundred
robots to a warehouse and deploy them
and that's kind of a lot of money so we
actually run our simulator so we run the
same code that runs on the robots in
kubernetes we scale that up to like
silly things that wouldn't be practical
in the real world and we are then
testing our system the same way that it
will be actually stress tested in the
real world so it's another place where
kubernetes is like super useful for us
and another reason why it's a really
great platform in general yeah we do
something pretty similar actually I mean
no robots for us but we you know we run
an endpoint on agents and I can just
build the endpoint into containers and
you know it's been a hundred a thousand
of them up in a kubernetes cluster and
just point them somewhere so we we
basically do the same thing and it's a
really easy way they just sort of have a
really elastic oh you know cool let's
let's point a hundred of these at that
well like you know do we have enough
capacity there which gives us a good
understanding of the number of endpoints
that can correspond with what size pods
and
how many pods what is our horizontal
scaling look like so now if you move
back to database questions
so how database is stapled so how do you
use together with a kubernetes are you
putting database in the Correa's pod or
so we don't run our databases inside
kubernetes we use cloud sequel it's
great it just runs we don't think very
much about it
the way kubernetes talks to cloud sequel
it's got a couple of intermediaries so
we use the cloud sequel proxy which is
designed to proxy between things like
kubernetes and cloud sequel Google
distributes it you just kind of tell it
to go and we run Postgres which means we
also need some additional connection
pooling so each of our customer pods
excuse me each of our customer name
spaces has cloud sequel proxy instances
and PG bouncer instances as like an
additional connection pooling layer
there we actually started running
databases inside containers again being
more cautious
Postgres for cloud sequels in beta and
we are like well we'll just wait and so
we waited in that time we had decent
success kubernetes is a you know pretty
stable platform using persistent volume
claims which allows you to have a disk
that follows your pod around we had
minimal minimal problems but certainly
the effort was not in 0 I spent a lot of
time tuning that we when we had the need
for a read replica that was a couple
weeks out of my time to make that a
thing and since moving away from that
model and and then there was also the
problems and so the problems are like Oh
alert just went off I'm running out of
disk space go in there and get more disk
space that's not a problem on cloud
sequel just that Auto scales right up
for you and so that was the that was
actually the main thing that I was
running away from and that I finally
came out of beta I was like ok great no
more disk space problems you know better
alerting and you know looking forward to
the day where also auto scaling on cloud
sequel takes that out of the equation
for me as well
so hard whenever you have to create a
instance in the classical are you using
kubernetes or a terraform to automate
that old process yeah so our our whole
thing is driven by terraform we you know
I've been using terraform for quite a
few years it's a great product and what
it allows me to do is create what's
called a terraform module which is much
like what Steph was alluding to for an
operator but that module represents what
is a customer and that customer is a
cloud sequel instance a DNS entry
namespace and all this other stuff and
then there's this tool called Atlantis
which allows you to manage all of these
things through github pull requests and
so essentially an upgrade in our in our
world as it get a pull request and then
Atlantis runs terraform and makes all
those things happen so it's really
really elegant for us but you know
there's always room for improvement and
that sort of thing yeah for us it's all
driven by our operator which is a daemon
that we wrote it runs in kubernetes but
it isn't part of kubernetes right it
could run anywhere we put it we just we
run everything in kubernetes so that -
and it goes it calls the API for cloud
sequel creates it you know waits for it
to show up make sure it does what what
it wants and then it creates everything
else all right so I think we are all
most of the time for Q&A but one asked
last question how many DBA is do you
have in your team just just me really I
would I would say zero only because I
don't consider myself a DBA so I am the
guy that's on call I guess
[Music]